das ist ein absolutes rätsel ein
ameisenstaat größer als deutschland eine
gigantische super kolonie die sich über
achtung 5000 kilometer entlang der küste
italiens bis nach nordspanien sieht die
argentinische ameise hat diesen riesigen
ameisenstaat gegründet doch wie kann es
zu der bildung einer solchen riesigen
super kolonie kommen das widerspricht
nämlich der evolution eine
österreichische forschungsgruppe hat
erstmals antworten auf dieses mysteriöse
phänomen krieg zum science fiction steak
gespann des seins videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
die argentinische ameise ist ein
tödlicher feind für die heimischen
ameisen atmen denn sie breitet sich
rasant schnell aus und verdrängt die
hier ansässigen am meisten in der
fachsprache ist von einer invasiven art
die rede die argentinische ameise wurde
schon in der ersten hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts nach europa
eingeschleppt und zwar mit dem schiff
diese ameisenart hat die fähigkeit sich
zu gigantischen super kolonien
zusammenzuschließen das geht über weite
distanzen hinweg hierbei schließen die
tiere staaten mit zahlreichen königinnen
zusammen deren untertanen gut
miteinander auskommen und kooperieren
das ist eine echte seltenheit der
normalerweise ist es und da meisen
üblich gegen den unmittelbaren
nachbarstadt in den krieg zu ziehen
bei den eingestellten argentinischen
ameisen ist das aber anders eine enorm
große super kolonie in europa zieht sich
von der italienischen küste bis hin zum
norden der iberischen halbinsel
also bis nach nordspanien es handelt
sich genau genommen also um viele
zusammenhängende am meisten staaten mit
sehr vielen königin deren individuen
kooperieren und sich wie eine einzige
kolonie verhalten aggressives verhalten
gibt es unter ihnen nicht und genau das
macht sie ebenso erfolgreich dazu
schreibt ein österreichisches
forschungsteam in einer aktuellen studie
einzelne kolonien zeigen kein
feindliches verhalten zueinander wenn
man tiere von der küste italiens
frittieren von der küste portugals
zusammensetzt gibt es keine aggression
das ist erstaunlich denn normalerweise
reagieren ameisen aggressiv aufeinander
selbst wenn die nester nur ein paar
meter voneinander entfernt sind
doch fachleute können sich bislang nicht
erklären wie es evolutionstechnisch dazu
kommen kann werden etwa diejenigen
eigenschaften die die ameisen kooperativ
machen
anderen erbgut teilen vorrangig
weiterhin geben liegt es etwa daran dass
den tieren ihre genetische vielfalt
verloren gegangen ist und somit auch die
fähigkeit zwischen ihrer eigenen kolonie
und einer fremden gruppe zu
unterscheiden
eine weitere these zielt auf die
verwandtschaftsverhältnisse ab da diese
nicht mehr so eng sind könnte die
toleranzgrenze der tiere für ihre
artgenossen möglicherweise steigen doch
das sind alles spekulationen die
wissenschaftlich nicht abgesichert sind
denn das große problem hierbei ist
tatsächlich die langsamkeit der
evolution dazu heißt es in der studie
es ist schwierig die mechanismen zu
finden die dazu führen dass super
colonia lied entsteht wenn man nur den
endpunkt der entwicklung betrachten kann
das forschungsteam aus österreich hat
dieses mysteriöse phänomen jetzt genauer
untersucht dazu einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler florian steiner super
kolonien sind aus evolutionstheoretiker
sich problematisch weil sie damit nicht
erklärbar sind es müsste einen
mechanismus geben der dazu führt dass
die genetischen eigenschaften von
individuen die besonders kooperativ sind
sich dann auch besonders häufig in der
nächsten generation wiederfinden das ist
bei super kolonien aber nicht der fall
zusammen mit seinem team macht der
experimente mit einer ameisenart die in
den österreichischen alpen heimisch ist
und ebenfalls in der lage ist große
kolonien mit mehreren königinnen zu
bilden
die ameisenart tetra mori um al pesto
eignete sich besonders gut für die
untersuchung denn sie bildet nicht nur
größere super kolonie ähnliche gruppen
mit mehreren chefin sondern auch
kleinere wehrhafte gruppen mit nur einer
königin diese ameisen sollten also
helfen den mysteriösen phänomenen auf
die schliche zu kommen
denn sie befinden sich ja quasi eben
mitten in der evolutionären entwicklung
hin zur ausbildung von super kolonien
das forschungsteam sammelte zunächst im
gesamten alpenraum tiere ein und
dokumentierter das verhalten der gruppen
sehr genau dazu wurden einzelne
individuen gegenübergestellt und
beobachtet was passiert verhalten sie
sich friedlich oder zeigen sie sich
aggressiv unter anderem wurden sehr
detailreiche videoaufnahmen davon
angefertigt auch das jeweilige netz der
ameisen wurde untersucht dann ging es an
die analyse des erbguts um
herauszufinden ob die verwandtschaft
eine rolle spielt und wenn ja wie groß
dieser einfluss ist die ameisen
expertinnen wollen anhand der dna
herausfinden welche verhalten
weisen vererbt sind die erna der tiere
dagegen lässt rückschlüsse darauf zu
welche erbteile tatsächlich aktiv sind
somit wollen die fachleute verstehen
welchen einfluss bisherige erfahrungen
haben
bislang wurden jedoch nur die dna daten
ausgewertet und hier sind die ergebnisse
eindeutig die tiere die sich ähnlich
verhalten zeigen keine eindeutigen
überschneidung laut florian steiner wäre
es zitat großartig wenn es zb die
expression von einem oder weniger gene
darüber entscheidet ob sich ein
individuum aggressiv oder friedlich zu
individuen einer anderen kolonie verhält
die ergebnisse der forschung könnten von
enormer bedeutung sein wenn sie zu einem
besseren verständnis solcher
biologischer invasoren für die heimische
fauna führen denn klar ist diese stellen
eine besondere gefahr für fremde
ökosysteme der weltweit passiert es wohl
mehrmals am tag das gebietsfremde arten
eingeschleppt werden unglaubliches
insekten sterben in deutschland niemand
weiß warum anklicken anschauen und
clixoom nature auf jeden fall abonnieren
ich freue mich über jeden der dazu kommt
bis dann bleibt dran